halfway into her last time as German
Chancellor if anything Angela Merkel is
sounding more ready than ever to take on
more global responsibility we have the
responsibility to solve the tensions
between Russia and Ukraine
unless Libya is stabilized the whole
region in Africa will become unstable
and that's why this is our task Europe
must leave a footprint as one might say
today in solving the conflicts in the
world and that footprint is looking
increasingly French as president Amano
amico makes sure he is seen to take a
lead in Europe meeting Russian President
Vladimir Putin he has pushed Germany out
of the diplomatic driving seat over the
Ukraine conflict McCaw also took the
lead in trying to negotiate a meeting
between Iran's president rouhani
and u.s. president Trump it's less than
a year since Germany and France renewed
their political vows by signing the
Allan Treaty of bilateral cooperation
but in this political marriage present
McCoy is increasingly seen as the one
wearing the trousers and the think tanks
are beginning to talk he can't stand the
Chancellor's making space for macro
without setting her own agenda as part
of that hon treaty German and French MPs
held their second joint session in
Berlin last week McCall sent his top
diplomat for Europe who found German
foreign policy restrained
unlike in France we are not used to
coalition's we are in a system where we
have more freedom of movement I would
say more capacity to be agile in the
current situation of the global crisis
we see this is sometimes an advantage a
French MP who was in the room also sees
Merkel's leadership qualities limited by
her lack of political space Manzi the
CEO we all see how calm she is in the
face of adversity but she isn't free to
act as she would like to have is
immersed having to share the government
benches with a Social Democrat SPD party
appears to be keeping
from taking more of a European lead key
Merkel Advisors say the demand for
German leadership is not being met that
should be our role real politics look
slightly different not only in this
country do we have a coalition so we
always need to find compromises the
opposition is less diplomatic we have a
huge lack of leadership and lack of
initiatives coming from Germany what we
see is is a government in this country
which is which is done there they are
tired
stability and compromise have been the
hallmark of MCOs policy architecture for
just over 14 years that formula alone
may no longer be working GLaDOS
Angermann
I believe that from the outside Angela
Merkel is already being regarded as a
kind of lame duck who has entered the
end face of her term and has little left
that she can shake on Angela Merkel has
survived many attempts to declare the
end of her political career but in the
autumn of her last term as Chancellor
the woman long seen as the leader of
Europe is fast running out of
opportunities to demonstrate that
leadership let's talk about this more
with political correspondent
maximilliana Russia - joining us now
good morning to you thanks for coming in
you know just last year Germany had the
initiative on a number of foreign policy
fronts on Iran Ukraine migration it
doesn't anymore it lost at an issue
what's happened in Berlin
life and the grand coalition is what
happened so we've seen the German
government that currently consists of
Merkel's party the conservative CDU her
sister party the Bavarian CSU and the
Social Democrats having like had a long
time of forming this government it was
almost a record time of several months
until they were able to form this
government and then they were directly
thrown into crisis mode over domestic
politics who's on migration they
couldn't find a coherent line there and
then other topics took over we've seen
that the climate crisis has become a
defining topics for voters here in
Germany with the rise of the Greens
becoming a stronger party and
that has determined politics in Germany
more than foreign policy
okay well Germany recently hosted the to
apparently get some kind of new
initiative the the first big meeting of
the new alliance for multi
multilateralism 50 nations committing
themselves to boosting international
cooperation is this group approach the
new face of German foreign policy if
talking in terms of how German
Chancellor Angela Merkel sees is
probably she's always been a champion
for kind of like solving things in a
bigger group she's always been a
champion of multilateralism and some say
that the election of the u.s. president
Donald Trump has been one of the
motivators to keep her in office to run
for this last term and yes so it has
been for policy terms that to keep up
this multilateral Liberal Democratic
World Order has been one of her like
defining issues and foreign policy
okay well Germany in the autumn of on
lamech will return to the initiative
will it gain the initiative again what
can we expect from German foreign policy
during the second half of this
administration well especially what it's
going to be interesting is into looking
how Germany is going to position itself
within Europe we've heard that the
French president amount of a macro is
then taking the lease in now how to
shape and define foreign policy or
policy in general in Europe and it'll be
interesting to see where Germany and
especially the German Chancellor Angela
Merkel is going to position herself and
as we are celebrating or is so
celebrated today the 70th anniversary of
China especially going to be interesting
how Germany is going to position itself
and like relation to China it is the
most important trading partner and it's
going to be interesting how Germany
within Europe is going to find a stance
on China's rise to global power okay now
if the Germany realigns let's say
somewhat with China wouldn't that risk
its relationship with the United States
that is exactly the conundrum Germany
isn't at the moment it is their most
important trading partner China to
Germany at the same time it needs to
think how Europe and Germany within
Europe is going to play a role into how
the tensions between China and the US
are currently happening in the Chinese
US trade wall okay we'll see where all
this is headed most of the IANA
Koscheck for estate thank you very much